c'est un moment du débat qui est
intéressant puisque je remercie le
rapporteur d'avoir porté cet amendement
dont nous avions fait auprès du
gouvernement je vous le rappelle chers
collègues une vraie ligne rouge
il est intéressant ce débat pour deux
raisons
il est intéressant d'abord parce que on
assiste à un rarement
d'une presque convergence entre nous ça
a été Rare il faut le souligner il est
aussi intéressant sur le plan politique
parce que vous voyez durant ces derniers
jours j'avais été accusé puisqu'à
l'origine aussi de cette amendement
j'avais été accusé de vouloir absolument
une politique nataliste et que la
politique catalyse était l'abomination
des abominations et je vois qu'il y a
une grande partie de la gauche qui est
restée fidèle à son héritage l'héritage
du Front populaire qui a inventé
la location familiale universelle
enrichie ensuite avec le gaullisme le
CNR ils ont fondé les socles d'une
politique familiale nataliste pour ceux
qui aiment l'histoire bien sûr il y a
une petite partie de la gauche
rare ici dans notre hémicycle qui
considère que évidemment la famille ça
n'est pas une valeur et que il faut
déconstruire tout cela qu'il faut
tourner le dos à ses cadres collectifs à
un destin commun au profit d'une
émancipation individuelle radicale mais
je suis heureux que au Sénat il yesset
de gauche social qui persiste et je me
suis toujours
j'ai regretté dans ma prof à vie
politique des dérives idéologiques pour
pouvoir le dire ici au sujet de la
gauche c'est un homme fondamental parce
que l'impensé de la réforme du
gouvernement c'est la démographie un
régime par répartition c'est un régime
justement de transition démographique et
intergénérationnel les femmes sont déjà
les grandes perdantes puisque vous
l'avez tous souligné les maires de
famille encore plus puisqu'on écrase les
trimestres de majoration avec les deux
années de recul c'est quelque chose de
fondamental on ne peut pas penser
l'avenir notre régime sans une politique
familiale qui soit une politique
familiale vraiment vigoureuse et
volontaire
[Musique]